♪
>> YOU JUST TAPPED INTO "THE
GROUP CHAT" LIVE IN THE "THE
BLEACHER REPORT" APP PRESENTED
BY FAN DUEL.
I'M GREG IVEY ALONGSIDE LIV.
THE NUGGETS LOST A TOUGH ONE AND
THE JOKER, HE TIED LARRY BIRD'S
ALL-TIME RECORD FOR
TRIPLE-DOUBLES.
TALK TO US, TALK TO US LIV, TALK
TO THE PEOPLE.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING ON THIS FINE
TUESDAY?
>> I'M TRYING TO STAY VERY CALM
ABOUT THIS NUGGETS TEAM RIGHT
NOW.
I'M TRYING TO BE PATIENT WITH
THEM.
THE INJURIES THIS TEAM HAS FACED
THIS YEAR ARE DEFINITELY TAKING
A TOLL.
MURRAY ISN'T BACK.
FIRST IT WAS MPJ.
NOW IT'S DOZIER, SO I REALLY
THINK THAT THIS NUGGETS TEAM
KIND OF NEEDS TO HIT THE REFRESH
BUTTON WHEN IT COMES TO THEIR
DEFENSE.
IN THE GAMES THEY LOST LAST
NIGHT, ALL OF THEIR STARTERS HAD
14-PLUS POINTS SO OFFENSIVELY
THIS NUGGETS TEAM ISN'T REALLY
STRUGGLING.
ON DEFENSE THEY ARE, AND AS
GREAT AS JOKIC IS, HE CAN'T DO
IT BY HIMSELF SO I THINK THEY
KIND OF NEED TO RE-ESTABLISH THE
ROLES WITH ALL THE INJURIES THIS
YEAR AND HOPEFULLY PULL IT
TOGETHER, BUT I'M NOT GOING TO
HOLD MY BREATH.
I'M TRYING TO STAY CALM AND JUST
RELAX.
>> LIV IS STAYING CALM.
SHE'S STAYING RELAXED ABOUT HER
NUGGETS.
I'M STAYING CALM AND I'M KIND OF
STAYING RELAXED ABOUT MY BETS
LATER TONIGHT, BUT WE'RE
EXCITED.
WE'RE EXCITED TO HAVE YOU BACK
ON THE SHOW, LIV, AND AS ALWAYS
WE'RE GIVING AWAY LOTS, AND
WE'RE GIVING AWAY JERSEYS, AND
WE'RE GIVING AWAY HOOD, SO YOU
GUYS.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND DO WHAT
YOU DO.
I NEED GIFTS.
I NEED EMOJIS, AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, LIV, ON THIS SHOW,
THE PEOPLE KNOW, WE WANT WINNERS
AND WINNERS ONLY, PLEASE.
TODAY, I JUST MENTIONED TUESDAY,
IT IS TNT TUESDAY.
FAN DUEL IS BOOSTING THE THREE
BY TWO IN NOT ONE BUT TWO, BOTH
GAMES TONIGHT MAKING IT THREE BY
TUESDAY.
THE QUESTION IS WILL THERE BE
TWO THREE-POINTERS IN THE FIRST
THREE MINUTES OF THE GAME?
TODAY WE ASKED YOU ON TWITTER
WHICH THREE BY TWO WILL CASH
TONIGHT?
IS IT THE NETS, THE MAVS, THE
CELTICS, THE LAKERS?
HERE ARE THE RESULTS, LIV.
TELL ME.
TELL ME, TELL ME.
IS THIS LIKE -- I DON'T -- I
THOUGHT THIS WOULD BE THE OTHER
WAY, LIV.
I HONESTLY THOUGHT THAT THIS
WOULD BE THE OTHER WAY.
I NEED THE PEOPLE IN THE
COMMENTS TO TELL ME WHICH THREE
BY TWO DO THEY THINK IS A LOCK.
LIV, BOTH OF THESE THREE BY TWOS
ARE PLUS MONEY.
WHICH ONE DO YOU LIKE BEST?
>> I'M KIND OF WITH YOU.
I THOUGHT THAT WE WOULD SEE THE
NUMBERS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY, SO IT LOOKS LIKE
I'M FADING THE PUBLIC HERE.
BOTH PLAYS ARE GREAT PLAYS.
HOWEVER, CONSIDERING THE FACT
THAT BOTH BROOKLYN AND DALLAS
ALLOW THE TOP TEN FEWEST THREES,
I DON'T LOVE THAT PLAY RIGHT OFF
THE BAT.
AS FOR THE CELTICS/LAKERS
MATCHUP, IN THE LAST TWO GAMES,
TWO THREES HAVE BEEN ATTEMPTED
BY THE CELTICS IN THE FIRST
THREE MINUTES.
NOW IT'S A MATTER OF WILL THEY
MAKE THEM?
THAT'S THE TRICKY PART.
>> RIGHT.
>> BUT WHAT HELPS THEM TONIGHT
IS THE LAKERS RANK BOTTOM TEN IN
THREE-POINTERS ALLOWED, AND
DEFENSIVELY THEY GUARD THE
THREE-POINT LINE AT AN AVERAGE
RATE, SO I LIKE IF THE CELTICS
TEAM KIND OF CONTINUES ON THAT
SAME TREND, THEY ARE PUTTING UP
THREE-POINT SHOTS EARLY ON.
NOT TO MENTION YOU'VE GOT A
LAKERS TEAM THAT HAS THE SECOND
FASTEST PACE, SO I -- I COULD
IMAGINE IF THE CELTICS ARE, YOU
KNOW, PUTTING UP THREE-POINT
SHOTS EARLY, THE LAKERS WILL DO
THE SAME.
THEY LIKE THE GAMES VERY
FAST-PACED, SO I'M LEANING
LAKERS/CELTICS IN THIS THREE BY
TWO TO BE HONEST WITH YOU, BUT
NOW I'M FEELING A LITTLE NERVOUS
BECAUSE IT LOOKS LIKE I'M FADING
THE PUBLIC.
I'M FADING TWITTER PEOPLE SO
WE'LL SEE HOW IT GOES.
>> LIV, FROM BETTING EXPERIENCES
THERE IS NOTHING WRONG WHEN
FADING THE PUBLIC.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH
HEIM IN THE COMMENTS.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS SEEING IF
THEY ARE ROCKING WITH YOU.
I'M SEEING IF THEY ARE GOING
AGAINST YOU, BUT IT LOOKS
LIKE -- IT LOOKS LIKE THEY MIGHT
BE ROCKING WITH YOU.
I'VE GOT RIPE 6 SAYING THE
CELTICS AREN'T GETTING PAST A.D.
AND LBJ TONIGHT.
LOVE THE TAKE.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A HEED.
I'M ALSO IN THE COMMENTS.
I SEE MAXWELL REXAL SAYS
BOSTON/L.A.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU, MAX.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I ALSO SEE JOE YAN IN THE
COMMENTS.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU, JOE IS ROCKING
WITH BOSTON/L.A.
SOME OTHER PEOPLE ARE ALSO --
JULIO HERNANDEZ ROCKING WITH THE
NETS AND MAVS.
GO BLUE.
NETS/MAVS.
I'M GOING TO CALL IT THOUGH.
I'M GOING TO CALL IT, LIV.
I'M GOING TO MAKE A DECISION.
WE ARE ALL RIDING YOUR PLAY,
LIV.
SENDING YOU GOOD VIBES, SENDING
THE GOOD VIBES TO L.A.
WE'RE RIDING THE BOSTON/L.A.
THREE BY TWO TONIGHT.
WHY NOT RIDE THE OTHER ONE?
SPRINKLE ON BOTH, RIGHT?
>> SURE.
>> GET PLUS MONEY ON BOTH.
LET'S ALL RIDE TOGETHER.
WHY NOT.
WE ASKED YOU IN THE APP, WE
ASKED YOU GUYS IN THE APP WHO
WILL BE THE TOP SCORER IN
TONIGHT'S BOSTON/L.A. LAKERS
GAME?
AT THE END, GET IN THE COMMENTS
AND TELL US, IN THE COMMENTS AND
TELL US WHAT YOU THINK.
AT THE END OF THE GAME WE'LL DM
ONE RANDOM PERSON WHO GUESSED
CORRECTLY AND HOOK YOU UP WITH A
JERSEY.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE CURRENT
ODDS.
LIV, YOU SEE THEM RIGHT HERE ON
YOUR SCREEN.
WHAT DO YOU LIKE?
WHAT'S STANDING OUT TO YOU?
>> SO, IF I WANT TO PLAY IT
SAFE, I'M GOING TO LEAN JAYSON
TATUM BECAUSE OF THE CELTICS
PERFORMANCE THE LAST TIME THAT
THEY PLAYED THE LAKERS.
HOWEVER, A LITTLE BIT OF A HOT
TAKE COMING FROM LIV MOODS.
I LIKE SCHROEDER.
I THINK THE VALUE IS GREAT.
WORTH A LITTLE SPRINKLE.
OUT OF ALL OF THE OPPOSING
POSITIONS THE LAKERS GIVE UP THE
MOST POINTS TO THE POINT GUARD
POSITION, AN AVERAGE OF 24 TO BE
EXACT SO THEY STRUGGLE TO DEFEND
GUARDS.
SCHROEDER IS COMING OFF A
21-POINT GAME AGAINST THE TRAIL
BLAZERS AND WILL BE FEELING
HIMSELF GOING UP AGAINST HIS
FORMER TEAM 2.
1 POINTS IN THE LAST MEETING
AGAINST HIS FORMER TEAM SO AT
PLUS 1,000 I THINK IT'S WORTH A
SPRINKLE FOR DENNIS SCHRODER, I
REALLY DO.
>> LOOK AT LIV THROWING THAT
CURVEBALL AT US, MAP.
THROWING THE CURVEBALL.
NOT TAKING THE SAFE PICK.
I LIKE THAT IS CORRECT LIV.
I ACTUALLY DO LIKE THAT.
MY GUY IS FACING HIS FORMER
TEAM.
HE'S FACING HIS FORMER TEAM.
USUALLY WHEN GUYS FACE THEIR
FORMER TEAM THEY STEP UP, SO
SHE'S ROCKING WITH DENIS
SCHROEDER.
I'M GOING TO PLAY IT SAFE HERE,
LIV.
I'M GOING TO PLAY IT SAFE WITH
LeBRON.
ROCKING WITH MY MAN LeBRON.
BOSTON/L.A.
LeBRON SHOWS UP IN THOSE GAMES.
THE LAKERS, THEY HAVE BEEN UP
AND DOWN, UP AND DOWN ALL
SEASON.
IT'S TIME FOR THEM TO KICK IT
INTO GEAR AND TO GET GOING AND
THE ONLY PERSON THAT WILL DO
THAT FOR THEM, THE ONLY PERSON
THAT LEADS THIS LAKER TEAM IS
LeBRON JAMES.
SEE HIM HAVING A BIG GAME.
IT'S NOT ABOUT WHAT I THINK.
IT'S ABOUT WHAT YOU GUYS IN THE
COMMENTS THINK.
I SEE LILL RENO 23 SAYS A.D.
HE'S ROCKING WITH A.D. TONIGHT,
PLUS 330.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
KENT GUARD SAYS BING BONG, RUSS
IS GOING FOR 36 AND 8.
LOVE, LOVE, LOVE THE TAKE.
J. SHY 13 SAYS IT'S GOING TO BE
TATUM FOR SURE SO SHOUT-OUT TO
EVERYBODY IN THE COMMENTS AND
SHOUT-OUT TO EVERYBODY THAT I
MENTIONED.
YOU'RE ALL WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
PLEASE REMEMBER AFTER THE GAME
WE'RE GOING TO HIT UP ONE OF YOU
GUYS AND HOOK YOU GUYS UP WITH A
JERSEY.
OF LIV, IT'S TIME FOR THE -- MY
FAVORITE PART OF THE SHOW.
LET'S TALK MAJOR MARKETS MONEY
LINES AGAINST THE SPREAD AND
POINT TOTALS FOR TONIGHT'S GAME.
THERE IT IS.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE ODDS.
LIV, WHAT ARE YOU SEEING HERE,
AND WHAT DO YOU LIKE?
>> WELL, WHEN I'M LOOKING AT
THAT NETS/MAVERICKS GAME, I
DEFINITELY LIKE UNDER 221.
OF 0% OF DALLAS' GAME GONE UNDER
AND 65% OF BROOKLYN'S GAMES HAVE
GONE UNDER.
I'M LIKING THE UNDER THERE.
AS FOR THE CELTICS GAMES, I
CAN'T BELIEVE I'M SAYING THIS,
BUT CELTICS PLUS FOUR.
I LIKE IT.
THE LAST TIME THESE TWO TEAMS
MET THE CELTICS WON BY 22
POINTS, AND BOTH TEAMS WERE
HEALTHY.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A QUESTIONABLE
LeBRON, A QUESTIONABLE A.D.
I KNOW THAT THEY WILL LIKELY
PLAY.
WE KNOW WHAT QUESTIONABLE MEANS
IN THE NBA.
IT'S KIND OF POINTLESS HONESTLY,
BUT THEY WON BY 22 POINTS LAST
GAME, AND I KNOW THEY HAD THAT
HOME COURT ADVANTAGE LAST TIME,
BUT THIS CELTICS TEAM ON THE
ROAD IS NOT BAD.
THEY ARE 9-4-1 AGAINST THE
SPREAD WHEN ON THE ROAD, SO THEM
NOT PLAYING AT HOME IS NOT
REALLY A DISADVANTAGE IN TERMS
OF THEM AGAINST THE SPREAD, AND
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THEY
DOMINATED THE LAKERS LAST TIME,
THINK I'M GOING TO TAKE THE
POINTS WITH THE CELTICS AT PLUS
FOUR.
>> I LIKE THAT A LOT, LIV.
I ACTUALLY LIKE THAT A LOT.
LET ME HOP INTO THE COMMENTS.
LET ME HOP INTO THE COMMENTS
BEFORE I GIVE MY TAKE.
I'VE GOT -- I'VE GOT NETS WIN.
I'VE GOT NETS WIN.
BO BLUE, SHOUT-OUT TO YOU AND
MAX, SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
HE'S ROCKING WITH THE NETS.
ROCKING WITH THE NETS TONIGHT.
HIT MAN ZAZA SAYS LAKERS MINUS
FOUR.
EVERYBODY THAT I MENTIONED
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
LET ME HOP IN HERE, LIV.
I WAS LOOKING AT THE GRAPHIC,
OH, I SEE TWO THAT I WANT TO
TAKE.
I KNOW WE WERE SUPPOSED TO PICK
ONE, AND THEN YOU COME AND DROP
TWO ON US, SO IT'S LIKE I'VE GOT
TO DROP TWO.
IT'S LIKE MANDATORY THAT I DROP
TWO FOR THE PEOPLE, AND WE'RE
GOING TO FIRST START OFF WITH
BROOKLYN.
LOOK AT THE MINUS 1 1/2.
THEY HAVE KEVIN DURANT ON THEIR
TEAM.
THAT'S WHY I'M BETTING ON
BROOKLYN.
THEY SIMPLY HAVE KEVIN DURANT ON
THE TEAM.
THIS IS LIKE A PICK'EM.
BASICALLY LIKE A PICK'EM.
I LIKE THE BETTER TEAM,  IN MY
OPINION, THE BROOKLYN NETS.
NEED JAMES HARDEN TO SCORE AND A
LITTLE FACILITATING.
I LIKE BROOKLYN IN THE FIRST ONE
AND IN THE SECOND ONE, LIV, I
LOVE YOUR PICK, THE BOSTON
CELTICS PLUS FOUR.
I BET BOSTON IN THE FIRST
MATCHUP IN BOSTON WHEN THEY WON
BY 20-PLUS POINTS, AND THAT WAS
A ROCKING CHAIR WIN.
IT WAS A ROCKING CHAIR VICTORY.
I WAS ABLE TO SIT BACK, RELAX,
ENJOY IT, LAUGH A LITTLE BIT,
CALL UP MY BUDDY.
IT WAS A REAL GOOD TIME WATCHING
MY BET CASH WITH NO SWEAT, SO
I -- I THINK I'M GOING ROCK WITH
THAT ONE AGAIN, LIMP SO
SHOUT-OUT TO LIV.
JUST THROUGH CURVEBALL AT US
WITH DENNIS SLOERD AND THREW THE
CURVEBALL AGAIN WITH THE TWO
PICKS.
LIV, YOU'RE ON A ROLL TODAY.
ARE YOU ON A ROLL TODAY.
WE TALKED MAJOR MARKETS.
NOW LET'S TALK PLAYER PROPS.
IT'S TIME FOR LOCK OR NOT.
I'M GOING TO PUT UP A PROP AND I
NEED ALL OF YOU GUYS IN THE
COMMENTS TO LET ME KNOW WHETHER
IT'S A LOCK OR IT'S NOT.
LIV, ARE YOU READY TO GET THIS
ONE ON?
YOU READY TO GET THIS ONE
STARTED?
>> I'M READY.
LET'S GO.
LET'S JUMP INTO IT.
>> LET GET RIGHT TO IT.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
FIRST UP WE HAVE MY GUY.
I JUST TALKED ABOUT HIM, LIV,
JUST MENTIONED HIM.
JAMES HARDEN TO SCORE OVER
21 1/2 POINTS TONIGHT IN HIS
MATCHUP VERSUS THE MAVERICKS.
THE ODDS ARE CURRENTLY AT MINUS
116, LIV.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
IS THIS A LOCK OR NOT?
>> I ACTUALLY THINK IT'S A LOCK,
I DO.
I REALLY DO.
I THINK JAMES HARDEN IS
CURRENTLY TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HIS ROLE ON OFFENSE WITH THIS
NETS TEAM AND I THINK THAT THIS
IS A GREAT GAME FOR HIM TO DO
THAT.
SOME OF HIS STRONGEST
PERFORMANCES HAVE COME WHEN HE'S
FACING A BOTTOM RANKED DEFENSIVE
TEAM, AND THAT IS THE MAV
RIFNLGS THE MAVERICKS ALSO HAVE
A REAL WEAK PERIMETER DEFENCE IN
TERMS OF THREES, AND WE'VE SEEN
JAMES HARDEN CAN HIT THE
THREE-POINT SHOTS WITH NO
PROBLEM, SO IF HE CAN GET THAT
STARTED FROM THE BEGINNING AND
STAY HOT FROM THE THREE AND, YOU
KNOW, FIND OPPORTUNITIES TO
SCORE SO HE CAN REALLY ESTABLISH
HIS OFFENSIVE ROLE ON THIS TEAM,
I THINK IT'S DEFINITELY AN EASY
CASH SO I LIKE IT.
I'M TAKING THE OVER.
I THINK IT'S A LOCK.
>> LIV IS TAKING THE OVER.
SHE THINKS IT'S A LONG.
I'M ALSO GOING TO TAKE THE OVER.
I THINK IT'S A LOCK SIMPLY
BECAUSE I JUST SAID THAT I'M
BETTING ON THE NETS TONIGHT TO
WIN THAT BALL GAME, AND IN ORDER
FOR THEM TO WIN THAT BALL GAME,
WE KNOW WHAT K.D. BRINGS.
HE'S A WALKING 28.
EASY WALKING.
IT CAN BE QUIET.
IT CAN BE LOUD.
IT CAN BE AGGRESSIVE,
NON-AGGRESSIVE, BUT K.D. IS A
WALKING 28.
WE KNOW WHAT HE'S GOING TO DO,
BUT JAMES HARDEN.
WE NEED YOU TO GO OVER TONIGHT
IN ORDER FOR THAT BET TO CASH,
SO COME ON, MAN.
WE NEED YOU TO GO OVER 21 1/2
POINTS G.SCORE SOME POINTS.
NEXT UP, NEXT UP, LIV, NEXT UP
IS PORZINGIS TO RECORD A
DOUBLE-DOUBLE IS SITTING AT PLUS
165.
LUFF, TALK TO YOU ME.
DO YOU LIKE IT, NO, MAYBE SHOW?
>> I DON'T LOVE THIS ONE TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU.
THE NETS RANK BOTTOM TEN IN
REBOUNDS ALLOWED, SO I COULD SEE
HIM MAYBE HITTING OVER TEN
REBOUNDS TONIGHT, BUT THE NETS
ALSO HAVE A TOP TEN DEFENSE IN
TERMS OF FEWEST POINTS ALLOWED
TO HIS OPPONENT AND WILL BE
GUARDED BY K.D. ALL NIGHT.
I DON'T THINK THAT PORZINGIS IS
THE GUY TO STOP THE K.D.
DEFENSE.
SCORING WORRIES ME A LITTLE BIT.
I THINK HE CAN GET SOME BOARDS,
BUT I DO WORRY ABOUT POINTS.
>> LIV, UNFORTUNATELY, I'M GOING
TO GO ON THE OTHER SIDE HERE.
MY MAN KRISTAPS HASN'T PLAYED IN
TWO GAMES.
I THINK HE'S GOING HAVE SOME
FRESH LEGS, LIV.
WILL HAVE FRESH LEGS.
GO GET 10-10.
I KNOW K.D. IS GUARDING HIM.
I'M BANKING ON HIM HAVING FRESH
LEGS SO I'M SAYING THE
DOUBLE-DOUBLE MIGHT BE A HOP.
LET ME HOP INTO THE COMMENTS.
I'VE GOT LITTLE RENO.
LITTLE RENO SAYS NOT.
BALLISLIFE SAYS NO WAY.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE AND FINALLY WE HAVE K.D.
TO SCORE THREE OR MORE
THREE-POINTERS, AND IT'S SITTING
AT 146.
LIV, TALK TO ME, TALK TO THE
PEEL.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
ALGORITHM REAPER, TALKING ABOUT
MY GUY K.D. HERE.
COULD YOU LIKE IT OR DO YOU NOT?
>> I DON'T.
I REALLY DON'T.
AS STRONG OF A SCORER AS K.D.
IS, HE CAN FIND OPPORTUNITIES
FROM WHEREVER.
I DON'T LOVE THIS PLAY AND WHEN
YOU'VE GOT A TEAM THAT'S FULL OF
SHOOTERS THAT CAN SHOOT FROM THE
THREE-POINT LINE, THERE'S NO
NEED FOR A GUY LIKE K.D.
STANDING AT THE THREE-POINT LINE
PRIORITIZING THREE-POINTERS ALL
GAME.
I DON'T LOVE THIS FOR HIM AND
THERE'S OTHER GUYS ON THIS TEAM
THAT WILL CAN TAKE THE
ATTORNEY/CLIENT POIT.
I DON'T -- CAN THEY DO IT.
WILL REDO IT?
DO I WANT TO WITH YOU MY MONEY
TON?
HE'S GOING GET BUCKET IN ALL
FACETS OF THE GAME.
HE MIGHT HIT A COUPLE OF THREES.
I DON'T KNOW.
I'M NOT PUTTING MY HUNDRED ON
THAT UP.
LIV, LET ME GIVE AWAY A HOPE.
>> LET ME DO IT.
>> HIT MAN ZAZA SAYS K.D. PLUS
THREE.
GOAT GARDEN SAYS NO FOR K.D.
SHOUT-OUT TO BOTH OF YOU, GUYS.
YOU'RE WALKING.
>> YOU CAN RIDE ALONG WITH US ON
FAN DUAL.
TON ON ITHE MY I GO WILL LOOK AT
THE PARLAY.
WHEN I GIVE THE PARLAY I NEED
EVERYONE IN THE COMMENTS TO TELL
ME WHICH LEG IS A LOCK, WHICH
LEG IS NOT.
WHICH LEG IS GOING TO CASH
EARLY, WHICH LEG IS NOT GOING TO
CASH EARLY.
GIVES GIVE ME ALL TYPES OF
COMMENTS.
THE GAME WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT MOST OF THE SHOW, IT
SEEMS.
THE BOSTON CELTICS TAKING ON THE
LOS ANGELES LAKERS.
ARE YOU READY TO GET INTO THIS
ONE, LIV?
>> YEAH, I'M DOING IT.
LIV'S READY, THE PEOPLE IN THE
COMMENTS I HOPE Y'ALLE OF ARE
READY IS MY MAN PRE-BRYN JAMES,
25-PLUS POINTS TONIGHT.
LIV, TALK TO ME, TALK TO THE
PART-TIME.
DO YOU LIKE THIS UP?
DO YOU SEE HIM SCORING OVER 25?
>> LeBRON HAS 30-PLUS POINT
GAMES IN THE LAST THREE GAMES.
I'M SURE HE'S GOING TO BE
LOOKING AFTER A LITTLE DEVENG
AFTER BEING DOMINATED BY THE
CELTICS TEAM OF EARLIER IN THE
SEASON AND THIS IS THE KIND OF
GAME WHERE LeBRON JAMES WILL
WANT FULL CONTROL ON OFFENSE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE JOB GETS DONE
EXACTLY HOW HE WANTS IT DONE.
I DON'T THINK HE HAS ANY
PROBLEMS HITTING 25-PLUS.
THE ONLY REASON THAT I COULD SEE
IT NOT HITTING IS THAT THEY
PRIOR TIDES A.D. AS THE SCORER
IN THIS GAME.
BECAUSE A.D. IS QUESTIONABLE AND
COMING BACK, I'M NOT SURE, BUT,
AGAIN, THIS STRIKES ME AS THE
TYPE OF GAME WHERE -- I LIKE HIM
IN THIS CAME TO -- ALWAYS A GOOD
THING.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT LEG OF
THE NEXT LEG.
YOU MENTIONED THEM SCORING, BUT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT REBOUND
HERE, LIV.
CAN A.D. GO AND GRAB EIGHT
REBOUNDS TONIGHT?
>> WELL, SO, IN A PERFECT WORLD
LeBRON WOULD BE THE PRIORITY IN
TERMS OF SCORING AND A.D. WOULD
BE THAT QUOTE, UNQUOTE BIG MAN,
SO HE SHOULDN'T HAVE A PROBLEM
HITTING THIS.
MY ONLY FEAR IS I'M NOT SURE IF
HE HIT THIS LAST GUAM AGAINST
THE CELTICS.
THE CELTICS ARE A PRETTY AVERAGE
TEAM WHEN IT COMES TO REBOUNDS,
SO THERE'S DEFINITELY A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES THERE FOR HIM TO
GET THESE BOARDS.
IT'S ALL A MATTER OF HOW THIS
LAKERS TEAM SHOWS UP.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IT BEFORE.
I'VE TALKED ABOUT IT LAST SEASON
WHEN THEY WERE ACQUIRING THIS
GUY AND HAD ALL THE TALENT.
THIS LAKERS TEAM IS HARD TO READ
AND THEIR ROLES ARE VERY
DIFFERENT AND KIND OF CHANGE
EVERY GAME.
IN A PERFECT WORLD LeBRON IS
SCORING AND A.D. IS THE BIG MAN
AND THIS SHOULDN'T HAVE A
PROBLEM HITTING, BUT THOSE
ROLES, MAN, I FEEL LIKE THEY
SWITCH AROUND.
THEY ARE PLAYING MUSICAL CHAIRS
WITH THEIR ROLES ON OFFENSE AND
DEFENSE SOMETIMES.
IT CAN BE A LITTLE CONFUSING.
>> YOU DEFINITELY HAVE A POINT
WITH THAT, DEFINITELY HAVE A
POINT WITH THAT.
THEY ARE FINDING THEIR WAY.
THEY ARE TRYING TO FIND THEIR
WAY.
I WAS ACTUALLY TALKING TO RON
ARTEST ABOUT IT THE OTHER DAY
TRYING TO FIND THE WAY THE
LAKERS FIT INTO THE ROLES THAT
THEY ARE MEANT TO PLAY.
MOVING ON TO THE THIRD LEG OF
THE PAR LATE.
IT IS MY GUY, RUSSEL WESTBROOKE.
AS A NEWCOMER ON THE LAKERS
TEAM, HE'S BEEN UP AND DOWN THIS
SEASON, LIV, BUT SIX ASSISTS,
THAT SEEMS LOW TO ME.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I LOVE THIS LEG OF THE
PARLAY.
I THINK IT'S EASILY MY FAVORITE
LEG.
RUSSELL WESTBROOK, WE SAW HIM
REALLY SHOWING OUT IN TERMS OF
SCORING ON THIS LAKERS TEAM IN
RECENT WEEKS, BUT THAT WAS WHEN
WE DIDN'T HAVE A.D. AND WE
DIDN'T HAVE LeBRON.
WITH THESE TWO GUYS ON THE
COURT, I THINK THAT RUSSELL
WESTBROOK'S MAIN PRIORITY SHOULD
BE FACILITATING.
HE SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON GETTING
REBOUNDS AND ASSISTS.
I DON'T THINK SCORING SHOULD BE
HIS PRIORITY.
I THINK HE -- THIS IS THE TYPE
OF GAME WHEN YOU'VE GOT A
HEALTHY LeBRON AND HEALTHY A.D.
HE JUST NEEDS TO HELP
FACILITATE.
SIX PLUS IS EASY MONEY.
THIS IS THE GUY THAT'S THE
WALKING TRIPLE-DOUBLE SO, YOU
KNOW, I WOULD HIKE HIM TO DO
THAT TONIGHT.
DEFINITELY BE A FACILITATOR.
NOT PRIORTIZED SCORING BUT
FACILITATING, ABSOLUTELY.
I LOVE THIS LEG.
>> THEY CALL MY MAN THE WALKING
TRIPLE-DOUBLE.
HE USED TO BE.
>> HE USED TO BE.
NOT SO MUCH ANYMORE.
>> BUT LET'S MOVE ON.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THIS LAST LEG.
WE'VE GOT THE GOOD VIBES FRV LIV
ON THE LAST WESTBROOK ASSIST.
THIS UP I'M HONESTLY SKEPTICAL
ABOUT.
JAYSON TATUM 3.3 THREE-POINTERS,
LIV.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING ON THIS ONE?
>> WELL, THE LAKERS ARE ALLOWING
THE -- A BOTTOM -- THEY ARE
ALLOWING THE BOTTOM TEN MOST
REBOUNDS OR I'M SORRY
THREE-POINTERS IN THE LEAGUE
RIGHT NOW SO I DON'T HATE THIS
PLAY AT ALL.
I THINK JAYSON TATUM IS THE TYPE
OF GUY WHERE HE'S GOING TO TAKE
THE SHOT.
WILL HE MAKE IT IS THE QUESTION
OF THE YEAR.
HE'S GOING TO TAKE THE SHOT NO
MATTER.
WHAT AGAIN, THIS IS A LAKERS
TEAM WITH A VERY QUICK PACE.
THEY WILL GET STARTED AND GET
HOT RIGHT OFF THE BAT AND JAYSON
TATUM.
IF THE LAKERS START PULLING A
LEAD THAT'S TOO BIG FOR HIS
LIKING.
HE WILL PULL UP FROM THE THREE
AND STAY THERE AND SHOOT BALL.
HOW WILL THE LAKERS TEAM SHOW UP
AND DEFEND THE THREE.
THAT'S THE ULTIMATE QUESTION
HERE BUT WE KNOW THAT JAYSON
TATUM IS GOING TO TAKE THE SHOT.
WE KNOW IF THEY HAVE ANY SORT OF
DEFICIT HE'S GOING SIT AT THE
THREE-POINT LINE AND TRY TO FIX,
THAT SO I LIKE THIS.
THREE PLUS, IT'S A LITTLE --
IT'S A LITTLE NERVE RACKING,
JUST A LITTLE BIT, BUT I
DEFINITELY THINK IT'S POSSIBLE.
HE'S DONE IT BEFORE, SO LET'S
JUST HOPE HE DOES IT AGAIN.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
I MEAN, LET'S PRAY AND HOPE THAT
HE DOES IT AGAIN.
LIV, LET'S PULL UP THIS TICKET
SO WE CAN SHOW THE PEOPLE AT
HOME WHAT THIS TICKET WILL COME
OUT TO BE.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR YOU TO GRADE
THE PARLAY.
SO WHAT DO YOU GRADE IT.
>> I'M GOING TO GIVE IT A "B."
I DON'T HATE IT.
A FEW ASPECT MAKE ME NERVOUS.
ANY TIME YOU TAKE A THREE PROPS
YOU SHOULD BE NERVOUS.
IT'S ONE OF THE PROPS WHERE THEY
WILL TAKE THE SHOTS TO HAVE YOU
ABSOLUTELY HIT THE BET AND THOSE
MAKE ME NATURALLY VERY NERVOUS.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF STRONG GUYS
WITH A LOT OF TALENT.
EVERYONE NEEDS THEIR OWN ROLE
AND TO STAY IN THEIR LANE.
DEPENDING ON WHAT THAT LANE IS
TONIGHT.
THERE'S A COUPLE OF PLAYS THAT
CAN MAKE THEM THEY ARIOUS, AND
WE'LL DEFINITELY BE SWEATING
THIS ONE OUT TO THE END.
I'LL GIVE IT A "B."
A GOOD SAME-GAME PARLAY BUT IT
WON'T BE EASY.
>> I'M GOING TO TAKE THAT.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW,
LIV, I AM IN THE COMMENTS GIVING
AWAY HOODIES, AND I'M ALSO
GIVING AWAY A JERSEY.
I'VE GOT NICOLE MARQUEZ.
GREG AND-OF-LIV, I'LL GIVE YOU A
B-MINUS THON PARLAY.
LeBRON WON'T MAKE 25 ESPECIALLY
AFTER BEING OUT FOR SO MANY
GAMES.
I KNOW HE'S HERE TO BEAT THE
CELTICS AND BEAT EVERYONE
TONIGHT.
A.D. AND LeBRON ARE THE DREAM
TEAM, BUT I DO THINK A.D. AND
RUSS WILL TAKE OVER THE SCORING
TONIGHT.
WINNERS ONLY MANIFESTING A
JERSEY.
LOST TAKE.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY.
SPICY ANGEL IS IN THE COMMENTS
SAYING AMINUS.
JAYSON TATUM IS THE ONLY ONE
THAT'S BRINGING US DOWN.
THANK YOU, ANDREW, FOLLOW THE
GOOFLD VIBES.
I'VE GOT LOOL 756.
GIVE US AN A-PLUS THAT SAYS
HAMMER IT.
LOVE THAT.
LOVE THE VIBES.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
SHOUT-OUT TO EVERYBODY WHO
COMMENTED AND SHOUT-OUT TO
EVERYBODY THAT I MENTIONED.
YOU ARE ALL WALKING AWAY WITH A
HEED.
LIV, STEVE KERR HAS REPEATEDLY
CALLED MY MAN DRAYMOND GREEN THE
BEST DEFENDER IN THE WORLD.
GREEN PROVED IT AGAIN ON SUNDAY
AGAINST THE SUNS.
HE BECAME THE FIRST WARRIOR TO
EVER RECORD NINE POINTS, NINE
REBOUND, NINE ASSISTS, SIX
STEALS AND THREE BLOCKS.
HE'S NUMBER ONE IN THE LEAGUE IN
DEFENSIVE RATING, AND HIS
TEAMMATES ARE CALLING FOR HIM TO
WIN 2021 DEFENSIVE PLAYER OF THE
YEAR, LIV.
I NEED EVERYBODY.
EVERYBODY HERE TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME IF DRAYMOND
SHOULD WIN DEFENSIVE PLAYER OF
THE YEAR, AND IF NOT WHO DO YOU
THINK SHOULD WIN?
LET TAKE A LOOK AT THE -- THE
ODDS ARE ALREADY UP.
DRAYMOND IS CURRENTLY SIGNATURE
AT PLUS 150, LIV.
IS THAT GOOD VALUE, AND WHEN ARE
YOUR OTHER FAVORITE BETS ON THE
BOARD RIGHT NOW?
>> I'VE GOT TO BE HONEST.
I THINK DRAYMOND GREEN IS MY
FAVORITE.
I HAVEN'T REALLY CONSIDERED
ANYONE ELSE AT THIS POINT.
DO I THINK 134RUS 50 IS GREAT
VALUE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GREAT.
BUT WILL IT GET ANY BETTER?
NO, ESPECIALLY IF THE WARRIORS
CONTINUE WINNING AS THEY ARE
HOT.
I THINK IN ORDER TO SECURE A WIN
LIKE THIS YOU NEED TO BE PART OF
A WINNING TEAM OF.
I THINK THIS WARRIORS TEAM OF IS
CAPABLE OF WINNING IT ALL.
I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE
VERSION OF DRAM GREEN WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW.
A COUPLE OF YEARS WHERE HE WAS
KIND OF PLAYING INSECURE
BASKETBALL AND I DON'T MOOEND
MEAN THAT IN A BAD WAY.
HE WAS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
HE'S BEST AT AND WHEN HE
PRIORITIZES DEFENSES AND DOESN'T
WORRY HOW MANY PEOPLES WE'RE --
I BET ON THIS GUY A LOT LOST
YEAR AND I WOULD GET SCREWED A
LOT BECAUSE HE'S NOT MEANT TO BE
FOCUSSING ON ME.
THEY NEED A GUY FOCUSING SLOWLY
ON DEFENSE AND THAT'S WHY THE
WARRIORS ARE ABLE TO BE SO
SUCCESSFUL.
I'M LOVING THIS VERSION OF
DRAYMOND GRAB, AND I THINK
THAT'S WHY HE'S THE CHOICE RIGHT
NOW FOR DEFENSIVE PLAYER OF THE
YORE.
>> I'M LOVING THIS -- I THINK
WHEN DRAYMOND HAS HIS SHEETINGS
AROUND.
HE TOELD.
I'M ALSO GOING TO RUN WITH
DRAYMOND GREEN.
BARRING IN ARE.
HE'S PRUS 150 FOR A REASON.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS THOUGH.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS LOOKING FOR
GOOD TAKES.
I'VE GOT MAKE HALE CANNON WHO
SAYS DRAYMOND IS A GOOD FINISHER
AND BLOCKER.
DISAGREE ON HIM BEING A GOOD
FINISHER AND HE DOES BLOCK A LOT
OF SHOTS.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
QB1 COACH SAYS ABSOLUTE HI HE'S
THE DEFENSIVELY MVP.
YES, YES, WARRIORS ARE THE BEST
NBA TEAM.
I'VE GOT ONE MORE IN TERM.
>> HE LEADS THE LEAGUE IN --
LEADS THE LEAGUE AND THE VALUE
IS NICE.
>> EVERYBODY THAT I MENTIONED
Y'ALL ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
LIV, I THINK IT'S TIME TO TAKE
THIS ON HOME AND GET ON PART OF
"THE GROUP CHAT."
THANK YOU GUYS FOR TAPPING INTO
"THE GROUP CHAT" PRESENTED BY
FAN DUEL.
REMEMBER WHAT YOU LEARNED TODAY.
THE BROOKLYN/DALLAS THREE BY TWO
IS A LOCK.
DRAYMOND GREEN SHOULD WIN
DEFENSIVE PLAYER OF THE YEAR AND
MAKE SURE YOU GET ON FAN DUEL TO
TELL OUR BR BETTING SAME GAME
PARLAY AND MY MAN CHARLES
BARKLEY, MAKE SURE TUNE INTO THE
"INSIDE THE NBA" PREGAME SHOW TO
SEE CHARLES CHOOSE HIS BEG LEG
OF OUR PAR LATE.
CANNOT WAIT.
WE'LL BE BACK NEXT WEEK GIVING
AWAY HOODIES.
GIVING AWAY JERSEYS.
GIVING AWAY LOCKS, AND IF YOU
WON TODAY, IF YOU WON TODAY, WE
WILL DM YOU.
NOT ME, NOT OF LIV, BUT BR BET
WILL GO REACH OUT AND DM YOU, SO
MAKE SURE YOU GET ON FAN DUEL,
RIDE WITH US AND FOLLOW US ON
SOCIALS ALONGSIDE LIV, I'M GREG
IVORY.
WE'RE LEAVING THE GROUP CHAT.
PEACE.
♪